[موسيقى]
صنعت في الصين وسافرت الاف الكيلومترات لم
تاتي هذه البضائع الى العاصمه الكنيه
وحيده هل جاءت ومعها كثير من المنافسه
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
[موسيقى]
قبل عشر سنوات اطلق الرئيس الصيني مبادره
الحزام والطريق حزام يمثل الطرق التجاره
البريه من الصين الى الغرب عبر الدول
المشاركه في المبادره طريق يمثل مسارات
بحريه تحمل البضائع الصينيه من اقصى شرق
البلاد الى البحر الابيض المتوسط غربه
يمتد هذا الطريق السريع الى قرابه 25
كيلومترا على خمس سنوات شرعت شركه صينيه
في انشائه ليصل شرقي العاصمه نيروبي
بغربها
الطريق السريع هذا اكثر من نظير بنت الصين
خلال السنوات الخمس الماضيه اكثر من مئه
كيلو متر من الطرق السريعه في البلاد بلغت
تكلفه هذه الطرق ما يقارب 200 مليون دولار
امريكي
مشاريع البنيه التحتيه الصينيه في كينيا
تمتد خارج العاصمه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من العاصمه السياسيه نيروبي الى العاصمه
التجاريه
بقرابه 480 كيلو مترا انشات الصين خطا
للسكه الحديد اربع عربات للركاب سبعه عشره
عربه للبضائع والهدف ميناء لامو ومومباسا
على المحيط الهندي
تمتد هذه السكه الحديديه من موانئ المدن
الساحليه جنوبا الى مدينه نيفاشا في
الشمال مرورا بالعاصمه نيروبي
التكلفه الاجماليه لهذا المشروع تجاوزت
خمسه مليارات دولار امريكي
الى السواحل الكينيه وصلت الصين ايضا هذا
ميناء مومباسا العاصمه التجاريه للبلاد
نفذت شركه صينيه مشروعه توسعه الميناء
باضافه ارصفه جديده الاهم من ميناء مومباس
هنا
مرفا لامو انشات شركه صينيه ميناء جديدا
بالكامل في مدينه لامو المجاوره
بلغت تكلفه المشروعين اكثر من خمسه
مليارات دولار امريكي
[تصفيق]
بعد نهايه حكم الرئيس الراحل دانيال عرب
موي الذي استمر 24 عاما اختار خليفته
موايكيباكي التطلع الى الشرق للحصول على
تمويل البنيه التحتيه والشراكات
[موسيقى]
منذ ذلك الحين اصبحت الصين الشركه
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه الرئيسيه لكينيا
منهيه هيمنه استمرت عقودا من قبل الدول
الاوروبيه والولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
الواردات الصينيه تشكل قرابه 40% من حجم
الواردات الى كينيا هناك الكثير من مشاريع
من التحتيه العملاقه الصينيه في كينيا
معظمها تم بشراكه مع الحكومه الكنيه
وبعضها شركه شركات صينيه خاصه من المتوقع
في المشاريع الصينيه في البناء التحتيه
تستفيد كينيا من هذه المشاريع بلا شك
الاهم تاسيس بنيه تحتيه لتحريك البضائع
داخل البلاد بشكل اسهل مقابل الاستفاده
الصينيه من الحصول على المواد الخام
بطريقه اسهل كذلك
[موسيقى]
هذه المشاريع مجتمعه فاقت تكلفتها 11
مليار دولار مولت بشكل كبير من الصين على
شكل قروض ميسره طويله الاجل من البحر الى
البر وبالعكس هكذا تحاول الصين ايصال
بضائعها من مصانعها البعيده الى متاجر
افريقيا والحصول على المواد الخام في
القاره طريقها في ذلك مشاريع عملاقه كان
لها دور كبير في رفع مستوى التبادل
التجاري بين الصين وافريقيا الى اكثر من
250 مليار دولار العام الماضي مرتفعا
بنسبه 11% مقارنه بعام 2021 لكن القلق هنا
من ان تتحول هذه المشاريع الى اداه سياسيه
للصين في افريقيا
عنوانها فخ الديون
يرد وزير الخارجيه الصيني هنا على ذلك
القلق ترى بيجين ان مصطلح فخ الديون دعايه
غربيه وخاصه من الولايات المتحده
يجب ان تكون الصين
اخر من يتهم بما يسمى فخ الديون تظهر
البيانات ان المؤسسات الماليه المتعدده
الاطراف والدائنين التجاريين يمثلون اكثر
من 80% من الديون السياديه للبلدان
الناميه تبذل الصين جهودا لمساعده الدول
الناميه في حل الصعوبات وهي اكبر مساهم في
مبادره تعليق خدمه الديون لمجموعه العشرين
[موسيقى]
على مستوى افريقيا ضمت مبادره الحزام
والطريق الصينيه اثنتين وخمسين دوله من
اصل خمسه وخمسين عضوا في الاتحاد الافريقي
نتج عن هذه الشركات الصينيه الافريقيه
عشرات الاف الكيلومترات من الطرق الاف
الكيلومترات من السكك الحديديه عشرات
الموانئ
ارقام هائله من المشاريع والاموال التي
ضختها الصين في القاره السمراء
الرئيس السابق قال انه سيظهر للعلن كل
بنود العقود مع الصين لكنه لم يفعل كثير
من الناس لا يعرفون تفاصيل هذه العقود ما
اذا كانت الصين ستمتلك هذه المشاريع في
حال عدم قدره البلاد على سداد الديون
العقود من الصين ميسره وطويله الامد في
المقابل الديون من الدول الغربيه لها شروط
كثيره ومعقده ومرتبطه بتفاصيل كثيره لذلك
تلجا معظم الدول الافريقيه الى الصين
لانها سريعه في انجاز المشاريع ولا يتطلب
الامر كثيرا من التفاصيل لتوقيع العقود
والبدء بتنفيذ المشاريع
بعد قرابه 100 عام من الاستعمار غادرت
بريطانيا يحتفل الكينيون بهذا الرجل اول
رئيس للبلاد بعد الاستقلال عام 64 من
القرن الماضي رغم استمرار العلاقه جيده
بين نيروبي ولندن الا ان الاهتمام الصيني
الملحوظ بالبلاد يفتح الباب على تحديات
امام من يوصفون بالشركاء التقليدي
تحديات فتحت القاره كلها لتكون ساحه
منافسه للاستثمار
كحدود غنيه بالموارد
وسوق مستعملها
يوما يا
مينا
صهيب العصا الجزيره نيروبي
[موسيقى]